juan branco et le retour merci d'être là
vous êtes avocat et vous croyez que vous
dites que selon vous les donations des
milliardaires sont des actes intéressez
vous vous êtes choqués par part se
soulève je trouve ça énorme naïveté sur
ce plateau alors vous prétendez ne pas
savoir comment ça fonctionne quand
bernard arnault surenchéri sur pino 10
12 heures après en disant au tamis 100
millions je mets 200 millions vous sait
très bien que les comportements bernard
arnault de dacca pas d'accaparement et
d'obsessions du projet à des niveaux
aussi dérangeant c'est vraiment par
brock ici dit les larmes sinon je vais
en mettre deux ans vous j'ai une
anecdote sur bernard arnault berne alors
vous l'aimez pas bernard arnault vous
avez créé à lire sur lui je n'entends
pas que sur lui sur la vielle également
pardon sur pino sur bolloré sur toi t'es
pas ils sont tous passés au tamis
bernard arnault j'ai une anecdote quand
jean luc lagardère meurt le grand
capitaine d'industrie qui avait fait
fortune et qui lisez concurrence mais en
arnaud décidant fait de contact et ça
veut il dire h intéressé par ton hôtel
particulier
est ce que je peux leur acheter ils leur
achètent et il lui dit à deux semaines
pour partir dans la foulée c'est des
personnes qui sont dans l'obsession du
grand john d'autres comme antoine
bernheim a gagné qui a qui a été la
personne qui a permis à bernard arnault
de faire sa fortune à partir de quoi à
partir d'un groupe industriel boussac
qui avaient été sauvées par l'état et
qui a été confiée à bernard arnault
contre le fait qu'il ne supprime pas
désemparé nous du des centaines de
millions de francs de subventions à
l'époque des années 80 pour contre une
condition vous licenciez pas les
employés textile qui notamment dans les
vosges sont en difficulté avant garde
toute l'histoire de pierre carles et non
du daily star fait bernard arnault
pardonnez moi mais c'est le tue
aujourd'hui presque 87
je veux venir comme un problème avec lui
je peux finir oui mais qui finit sur sa
taille de cette personne n'a fait
licencier trois mille personnes il a
détruit un tissu industriel dans les
vosges il
il a laissé une embauche il a bien peu
ces îles à dépecer lempire boussac qui
s'est débarrassé de toutes les
entreprises textiles à partir de tout et
vous avez de fraude et il a gardé les
marques les plus rentables du or grâce à
l'est roanne prendre rocco juste pour
vous dire si bernard arnault demain dis
moi je suis très riche le georges
laraque tout j'ai tout fait revivre en
décompte le nombre de gens qui seront
tous n'ont aucune avarie qu'une vous
savez pour arrêter
les 87 milliards d'euros ils viennent
grâce à la puissance par bernard arnault
avait cet argent sens unique et je vous
invite mais moi j'ai fait de voiture
j'ai écrit un bouquin la bonne foi ne
pouvez pas dire trouver panier pineau
soir l écoute et là parce que selon moi
je m'en vais
dites nous pourquoi vous a parlé du
courage à toi et on a laissé tomber mon
seigneur alexio pourquoi piscine de
résister et je suis d'accord avec vous
qu'il faut aller les chercher ces
milliards pour les pauvres
cent fois d'accord mais ne commençons
pas les miens grande richesse laisser
finir mon seigneur cr d'euros de fraude
fiscale très bien si vous voulez vous
attaquer les gens qui ont donné de
l'argent vous pouvez le faire mais quoi
je ne voudrais rien de regarder chis
mais bon on ne chasse que rural excédant
ce milliard à ce que représente ce
milliard d'euros comme heures de travail
comme artisanat pour 14 millions de
personnes qui viennent voir notre pays
sûr et c'est vrai ce qu'il fait
l'artisanat moi je vois lille de la
visite on a financé et bien sûr l'état
chargé des finances et il devrait pas
dépendre la charité on est d'accord
géraud notre invité ça s'appelait c'est
le finir une charge intéressés si vous
savez les harcèlent monsieur de la peine
bien sûr alors alors dans la hauteur
mais c'est sûr ça va dire que
malheureusement comme d'habitude
monsieur branco a beaucoup de mal avec
eux ce qui le dépasse ne met pas ce qui
vous dépasse qu'est-ce qui me dépasse il
ya des choses qui nous dépassent tous et
qui nous unissent
mais vous vous êtes toujours sur le côté
et là il ya quelque chose qui nous
dépasse je donne des nôtres d'un vente
pour créer un centre des arts nous
soyons des français est-ce que vous avez
quelqu'un d'aragon les croyants qui
s'illumine gers taureaux les millions de
personnes qui ne sont pas représentés
monsieur eric naulleau hermétique à la
grandeur vous il faut toute la chorale
mais arnaud de france dans la frange
dans laquelle vous aimez moi ont couru
3k ce 24 heures j'ai dû rester unie g
-sand éditions kaze moi qui étais déjà
montré les 18 jours sur le secteur les
corses vous êtes un héros
les briques et non j'ai essayé de mettre
ça vous êtes sur les défendre c'est la
seule vraie cause que vous défendez oui
mais